rules to cut emissions of major air
pollutants from machines ranging from
lawn mourners to build dozers tractors
and Inland Waterway vessels were backed
by Environment Committee MEP is on
Tuesday these vehicles account for 5% of
particulate emissions in the EU on
Tuesday European citizens talked about
their fears over the arrival of tens of
thousands of migrants in Europe and my
poor chair of the Foreign Affairs
Committee answer the three most
frequently asked questions on Facebook I
think we should support people to go
home if they have a safe home
destruction of cultural artifacts and
refugees lack of education or also
humanitarian and security questions
stressed UNESCO director-general Irina
Bokova during the public hearing on
Tuesday formula priority tienen que su
debe sewer
la destruction de Patri Mon downloadable
the Keystone humanitary security set up
a facility bill may met no on component
who on a purple year on paper fairly
chuan on for Humanity le diesel from
stabilizing the financial markets and
preventing systemic risks that threatens
the economy this is the mission of the
three European Supervisory authorities
the chairs were grilled by MEP is on
Tuesday except to us the parliament
representatives of the citizens to
follow very closely what are the
elements on which the mandate eventually
has got to be changed or adapted or if
everything is going smoothly the
Agriculture Committee recognized on
Wednesday the Commission's 500 million 8
package for farmers is a step in the
right direction but it might not be
enough to get those struggling with
Falcon prices back on their feet
let that tell collective Rudy Vallee zj8
homeys of course it could put them in
Vegas la santé
you'd be demolished by our Thursday a
vast majority of MEP s voted on an
emergency migrant irrigation scheme
placing a hundred and twenty thousand
asylum seekers in countries across the
European Union